el tema de que de los asados en general
en la gente alegría entenderse se vuelve
a bajar a palpitar es eso la gente está
contenta de cómo una sal y está feliz
eso es lo que genera comer un asado
asado significa también estar en familia
[Música]
yo como jurado estoy evaluando en la
presentación del plato de varios platos
cuatro en total y este el punto y el
sabor entonces de las ocho provincias y
evaluando esas diferentes puntajes
[Música]
pues nada que ahora mismo el convenio ha
comenzado la verdad venimos desde españa
de intercambio y bueno vamos a probar un
poquito esto que tienen bastante
[Música]
cuesta mucho el tema de la gastronomía
para la mujer porque por lo general
donde la manda en cuarto frío hacer
ensalada o postres bueno y podemos mucho
más que todo esto
[Música]